thank you so much renee from
carvin time out of your 27 hour day
you're one of those people in my life
who has three more hours it seems in
their day than the rest of us
thank you for having me ben i really
enjoyed that that was one of my first
ones and you came out there swaggy with
the sneakers and i thought okay
sneakerhead so i we felt the connection
right away
had the chance to host a show with renee
uh gm school where aspiring front office
executives for the nba got put through a
series of challenges and renee was one
of the judges you got a chance to host a
game show i would imagine growing up
playing basketball you never thought
game show host was going to be in the
future
now here you are as an owner of a
basketball team and what challenges are
next what dreams do you have next i mean
it's amazing to think about the things
you've been able to accomplish
yeah you know there's some exciting
things happening on my end but i'm
really excited about how
i've been allowed to mix my business
with philanthropy you know and just
having different things where i'm doing
things that i actually enjoy doing uh
but it it benefits the community as well
so it's the atlanta dream you know
becoming an owner of
a accompanied and of the
wnba that i spent my whole life giving
my blood sweat and tears to well you
better believe that i'm going to take
care of the brand i'm going to have fun
with it so for me there's there's a lot
of work but it's also a lot of pleasure
as well what's the day-to-day uh like
for you on the dream what are the
aspects of the opportunity that you
maybe didn't know were part of it going
into it but now that you've settled in
for some time that you really enjoy
you know the day-to-day it changes every
day um in the sports world things are
moving so fast so that's what i enjoy
you know whether it's you know i work
with suzanne a bear and larry and
they're both lawyer backgrounds so it
has a lot of long emails that i'm
reading they they are so good at
business that i'm trying to sponge at
all i mean with northland they're
running a billion dollar business and
doing it well so i want to take in
everything i can and it's also just a
pleasure to you know hop on random quick
calls if there's an emergency or we work
through things well but the things that
i cover with the atlanta dream mostly
are marketing and the community aspect
renee montgomery two-time wnba champion
future dancing with the stars champion
and co-owner of the atlanta dream
joining the show
uh tj and i have been loving watching
stewie play the last few weeks as i've
been here on the rich eisen show she
balled out over in the olympics then
last night wins the commissioner's cup
university of connecticut i know you've
had your eye on her for a long time
what's it like first of all not to have
to play against stewie anymore but also
just to watch her hoop in this summer
she's been incredible i think
stewie has been a leak it's like to say
the least and i always love to see that
you know she had that achilles injury
and that's a monster you know that's a
monster rehab that's very tough to come
back from but she came back if it's even
possible she came back almost better
than before the injury so you know she's
a yukon husky grad and we bleed blue
over here but i always love seeing
athletes have that come back in for her
to play like she did coming off of the
olympics jet lag where i mean it's just
unbelievable so i mean i wish nothing
but the best for her as i mean what else
can she do at this point
what a great way to kick off the second
half of the wnba season with the
commissioner's cup last night they had
to take the olympic break but now we've
got a few more regular season games
before the playoffs it really does renee
feel like w and the wnba and women's
basketball in general is having a great
moment long overdue a lot of household
names now icons in the sport what are
you most for looking forward to in this
second half of the season and just talk
to me a little bit about the state of
women's basketball
you know well you know i'm looking
forward to being i'm biased so i'm
looking forward to the atlanta dream you
know just seeing the practices and
seeing how the players have been gelling
and just the chemistry that's being
built i'm looking forward to us having
some sort of second half run and then
just
the the playoff run it's it's fun in the
wnba just like in all other sports it's
gonna come down to the last games and
teams are gonna be battling out in the
end so i'm excited for that and just the
future of the wnba is very bright when
you look at the the young stars in the
wnba when you look at the people that
are attaching themselves the brands that
are starting to get eyes on the wnba
everyone can tell the trajectory and so
for me as a player that when i came in
it was always scary if we would have a
season the next year or not you know
there was always talks of folding and
how stable is the wnba well that's long
gone now it's a very stable league with
a bright future
renee we joke on this show often that
the celebrity who makes sense in every
single room is snoop dogg if you see
snoop sitting courtside at a wnba game
yes snoop loves hoops there he is if you
see him at the high times awards kids
choice awards doesn't matter snoop makes
sense in the room
you are climbing up that list renee
you are climbing up the make sense in
the room list because you have so many
interests and passions outside of
basketball let's talk nfts you launched
an nft series with the heartland group
how did that whole thing come together
you know that was that was a part of me
basically heartland group produced my
podcast remotely renamed when it first
came out and so i already had that
connection made with them i already knew
their creativity was off the charts so i
told them my ideas you know we were very
specific we were like you know we wanted
to be a hologram we wanted to be this
and they brought every single idea to
life so it was really exciting i made my
nfts my starting five about
five big moments in my career whether
it's when i retired whether it was when
i broke the wnba record for threes and a
half just big moments in my career i
made five of them and you know they're
on open sea right now and it's exciting
because
the nft crypto world is exploding and i
hope that people support the women's
side like they do the men's side because
i've seen the numbers over there so i'm
hoping that some people start bidding on
my nfts because we really put some time
and energy into them
makes sense in the world of nfts and you
make sense in the world of gaming i know
you're up late nights twitching and
playing games and we were just talking
about all nintendo games you have to
blow on the cartridge gone are the days
of that with gaming but talk to me about
your gaming career and what you love
about video games as a grown woman by
the way
yeah as a grown woman let me blow your
mind the thing i love most about video
games is that my 13 year old son who is
in the gaming will think it's cool the
doper things i'm in so i want to be that
cool mom that is like in the fortnight
game that my son is playing and then
he's killing it in his fortnight game
and i'm popping up on the screen that's
goals for me so those are the kind of
things that get me excited i also am
really into tech so gaming goes hand in
hand with tech that world but i have a
child that loves gaming so you know you
kind of tend to veer towards what your
family's into
and i know you come from a family that
loves sports so to see you now
broadcasting games they must get a real
kick out of that you're out there doing
summer league you're doing atlanta hawks
games
what is it that you enjoy about
broadcasting and how do you connect to
the game or approach the game a little
different than as a player or an owner
or all these other ways you've been
involved
i would just like to say right now ben
you're killing it
as a guest host um i'm seeing tweets of
people tweeting about when are you gonna
guest host next so whoever's listening
in this right now y'all gotta have ben
back but yeah for me it's just staying
connected to the game you know it's
staying connected to a sport that i grew
up loving like i loved it since i was
young so when people hear me call the
games and they talk about my energy and
my excitement that's real i really am
excited and have energy for watching
whatever game it is because if it's
sport
i'm excited about it i love
competitiveness and i love the game of
basketball so it's just really been a
treat to be here in summer league where
you see some hungry players you see
players that are trying to make an nba
roster trying to change their lives and
so we saw technicals we've seen people
get thrown out we saw bloody ears bloody
eyes and people are going for it so for
me that's fun i like to see basketball
i'm a basketball purist so i love to see
people go at it renee i love watching
you on the broadcast i really appreciate
you calling in making our show better
today and what's so great about renee
and brockman you'll appreciate this as a
degenerate gambler absolutely renee pays
off on her bets oh in like a real way
and i interested i just want to say
thank you renee because the chosen
family chardonnay you sent me when the
knicks beat the hawks in december was
delicious
you know what this is like this is a
great example of sometimes you lose the
battle but you win the war because we
did we did lose that game to new york
and i had to send you that bottle of
wine but we know what happened in the in
the conference semis so
i'll take a wine to advancing in the
next round my friend i know i was just
about to say i also thank you as a
friend for not wanting to make a playoff
bet so thank you for that i really
i really do appreciate it
i don't i'm not going to get in the
habit of making bet that was like my
last one i realized that very quickly so
i should thank you for that because if i
start messing around and betting all my
friends on each team we play i'll be
broke i'm not doing that so you taught
me a valuable lesson i lost my first one
and i was like oh yeah that's it for me
yeah especially with those uh shipping
and handling charges from channing frye
and kevin love up there in oregon we
gotta get the the shipping and handling
down on the chosen family renee
listen i am i'm never gonna be mad at
what people charge to get their products
out and get their products right so i'll
pay it if you want it you gotta pay it
well i appreciate you uh you sending
that my way it paired nicely with the
grilled fish it was delicious
no problem and you know kelsey traynor
told me to say what up to her guy tj
jefferson
what up dj what up renee i was gonna say
the same thing to you about kelsey but i
just had a quick question for you renee
um the women of the wnba are always at
the forefront whenever
there's a wrong that needs to be righted
right and i appreciate and
you know really enjoy that fact that you
women are always first up
pounding the table for whatever wrong
needs to be righted how important is
that for you and for the rest of the
women in the wnba to always kind of take
that lead whenever something needs to be
changed
it's very important i think that the the
women of the wnba
understand their platform you know and
and sometimes it's not on athletes to
have to speak out but when athletes
understand their platform and want to
speak out it's very powerful and you can
see it you can see what happened in 2020
you can see what the atlanta dream
players did in 2020 you can just see
what happens when athletes collectively
collectively come together and use their
platform to speak on things that are
they're passionate about and so that's
why i'm proud to be a part of the wnba i
tell people all the time it's a
sisterhood and even though i'm now in
the ownership group i'm still part of
that sisterhood you can't tell me i'm
not still part of the squad so i'm
excited just to see you know where this
takes us because now companies the world
is starting to understand that yeah
there's things that are important and
there's sports but there's mental health
there's social justice there's different
things as well as sports and the world
is catching up to that the wnba has been
leading that charge since at least 2016.
so i'm happy to see the progress coming
on now
renee montgomery joins us the two-time
wnba champion owner of the atlanta dream
she got the nft drop with harlan
entertainment she's on the atlanta hawks
pregame post game i'm running out of
like accolades here i mean this is
ridiculous renee the the resume of ben
lyons don't forget the dopest line come
on now
27 hour day i'm telling you that's what
she's living also ben i don't know that
the rich eisen show has an official wnba
team i mean we're fans of them all but
you know from they wanted to dream we
couldn't remember the thing it was all
the dreams i used to remember the
magazine renee and i got a lot of room
over behind my desk to put you know
tchotchkes and you know
all types of atlanta dream stuff if i
were to receive something i'm just
putting it down
okay i gotta get the address i gotta get
the address we gotta send you a little
something to put up there that's what
i'm saying there's a lot of real estate
back here renee that's all i'm saying i
mean we like hoodies and show them we'll
take gear or
whatever renee their allegiance is up
for sale but you know who i'm rolling
with today you don't even have to ask do
you
stay less thanks fellas
renee montgomery joining the show
i root for the dream i want to see them
do well but you know i'm a sparks guy
parks guy till i died hey you watched
all the way to the end thanks for that
watch more right here